there is a new disorder it is called
SMED social media anxiety disorder and
I'm 99% sure that I suffer from this
this is the endless condition where we
find ourselves having to tweet and
Instagram all our food and constantly be
locked into this digital world and
they're actually starting to prescribe
this to people and say that this is a
real medical disorder do you guys do you
suffer from this Jen first of all I like
tripping out right now that my tweet
happening is first of all yeah any time
any new thing happens anytime culture
shifts anytime something happens they of
course have to associate or disorder
with it I don't know if it's necessarily
disorder more is just a natural
phenomenon that happens when people are
extremely tied to their devices I
certainly feel that I certainly will get
that like Facebook or it didn't happen
type thing which is insanity
I certainly find myself rabbit holing
into you know the web for a while and I
know they say people that spend more
time on the internet get more depressed
like and I can see how this is a real
thing but I'm also waiting to see what
pharmaceutical company wants to hop on
more to now prescribe whatever to detach
you from yeah and and one of the
fascinating things is that they show you
that you know you feel like you should
be more connected is what everyone says
well I want to be more connected with
everybody and yet they show you all the
time that you're more disconnected
because it looks like oh everyone else's
food is cooler and their Instagram
filters better
I like real syndrome so basically like
if you know in television basically when
you when you see a movie it's like
trailer syndrome you're seeing a best-of
so most people aren't like when I'm
sitting home in bed like eating nachos
sobbing time you finally depressed
Instagrammer that's just a bummer I have
to kind of go against a little bit of
what you guys are saying here just from
it's easy to be flip and kind of cynical
about this but truth be told this is not
a diagnosable disorder right now it's
not in the ICD it's not in the DSM so
all of the diagnostic tools that
physicians and psychiatrists and
psychologists use there's no such thing
as social media anxiety
disorder and so it does it's oftentimes
I think what happens is that if an
individual does have a clinical issue
with anxiety they're gonna be different
kind of behavioral aspects of their life
that they'll latch on to you know if you
look at a generalized anxiety disorder
it's a little hard to pinpoint but if
you look at obsessive compulsive
disorder that's also listed as an
anxiety disorder yeah and really what it
is is that there's there's an anxiety
welling up and that helps you kind of
keep it in check periodically and so it
could be that there are people who
already possess a deep anxiety and the
social media kind of addiction feeds to
that I think that there's also a like
you said a shift in culture and we are
connected to our technology now and yes
it it might make me nervous if I forget
my phone and I leave it at home for six
hours but is that because I'm afraid I'm
gonna miss that email from work that's
really important isn't it the same thing
as feeling nervous that like you don't
have your coffee your house keys handy
or or for whatever reason I mean I think
that there is a legitimate side to this
and it's easy for us to kind of like I
said be cynical about it but being
disconnected from your social media can
actually have adverse effects on your
work and your social life some people
this is their form of socialization yeah
and I don't see that as being
potentially negative I just see it as
being you know part of the world we live
in
do you guys think that part of this is
that we got all this stuff at once like
this is all new in the last 10 years we
got all of it and now it's like when I
walk my dog the other day I forgot my
phone and I walked for a half out of no
phone and the whole time I kept putting
my hand in my pocket like I've got to be
tweeting about the dog no I know and
then I loved it yes I loved it I
actually two Sundays ago I took the full
day off I announced it I am taking the
day off he's dead we're getting
somewhere he's not on Facebook must be
dead you're on Facebook or Twitter or
Instagram it'll check every single
Avenue Mageau have you been in there 20
like my sister ones I didn't update
anything for like two or three days and
she legitimately was like I was very
concerned that you had been sick it was
all
that's of course babies but of course
that's based on previous pattern because
you've probably never gone two days
before and I think that's important you
guys have like a particular one that has
more power over your day-to-day
operations is it for me it's Twitter by
this because we're all in this
talky-talk world so Twitter is just the
perfect nation breaking news you know
it's first trending topics you can kind
of expel information Facebook is for at
least for me more people I know what
they're up to and you're having a baby
and you just need a sandwich and
whatever but Twitter really is you can
tell what's trending what's on people's
mind I've completely given up on like my
personal Facebook I do have a page on
Facebook but I see that more as kind of
part of my daily promotional routine my
daily routine where I get in touch with
people and I kind of will sit at my
computer to work to do more page things
whereas with Twitter it's an all-day
everyday stream that's in my pocket I
very rarely will tweet from my computer
it's almost always from my iPhone so I
think I'm just much more active and that
I also don't Instagram or Pinterest at
all they do not interest me I'm sure
you're not planning your wedding at okay
basically it's like if you're a girl new
in Pinterest never show to your
boyfriend's designing a wedding it's
just it's a lot of wedding stuff it's a
lot of cats the cache in the internet
really I'm a dog yeah why do people love
that I'm a dog girl but cats are
hilarious I'm a cat person so I'm the
wrong person to talk about that's it
I've zero which is very strange
I'm like I said women are like like I
don't have any babies I'm sad I'm like I
have no keys how did he catch the
unknown I'm a cat person okay you don't
lady imaginary Wow